[Music]
instagram
you you i started an instagram account
yeah and you you got
instagram kind of a little bit peeved at
you was that what you say
i i mean i i started an instagram
account and
you know you gotta you gotta give
something back to the fans
yeah i mean sure so i thought the one
thing that fans you don't probably want
to see
is photos of me smiling in different
locations
and uh photos of the food i'm eating
okay
so let's take a look at this there's an
instagram photo that got you in some
trouble or
right instagram angry you took a picture
of yourself i think you're wearing
sunglasses here
yeah unfortunately there was uh
you know i was just trying to post a
photo for the fans but there was a
reflection in the sunglasses
of my computer screen and i didn't i
wasn't aware of that
when it posted and it was quite
embarrassing uh i don't know if you can
see
i can't really see maybe you tell us
what it is
i mean it's an old man uh
who's naked with an erect penis
on my computer screen and you know this
is private stuff that i'm looking at
whatever you know
i'm like doing it and it's just one of
those unfortunate
accidents you know where
you know there's a reflection why are
you wearing your sunglasses
when you're looking at male pornography
i you know what i do in my own time is
what i do it's like
okay also you did look very cool yeah i
mean yeah
i was kind of look cool i like
unfortunate reflection right
right okay now instagram made you take
that down
okay they took it down they took it down
now you came back with another picture
uh this is you holding a knife
[Applause]
what's going on here nathan i mean again
like you know
i just didn't know that there was a
reflection of my computer screen in the
photo
you know i like this particular image i
look at it sometimes
okay i just didn't while you're eating
you're eating food
it was just one of those accents that
you don't realize until you post it and
then you're like oh that's embarrassing
okay next one
rear view mirror i mean
[Applause]
how could that even happen i want to
walk over to the monitor and look up
closer and see it but
i'll freeze frame it at home oh my god
there's like a private thing that
happens accurately
you're just putting a laptop in the back
seat okay
sometimes i like to look at some of the
car all right